or on problem 47 47 on page 281 if the
two floors in a certain building are
nine feet apart how many steps are there
in a set of stairs that extends from the
first floor to the second floor of the
building so I think I can draw that so
this is this is the second floor this is
the first floor they want to know how
many there's they're 9 feet apart that's
what they tell us already now if you we
need to figure out how many steps there
are to go from the first to the second
floor so a piece of information one they
give us each step is 3/4 foot high foot
high
well this by itself should give us
enough information right because each of
this these distances I'll do it in green
each of these are 3/4 foot high so to
figure out how many total steps to get
to the top you just say 3/4 times the
number of steps is going to be equal to
9 and then you could just solve this by
multiplying both sides by 4/3 but we
don't have to solve it we just have to
know that we can solve for it so one
alone is enough right and you could what
if you multiply both sides of this you
get 12 that you need 12 steps but anyway
we don't we want to avoid having to
actually do math we just want to figure
out whether we can do the math piece of
information to each step is one foot
wide one foot wide well that's clearly
useless because it doesn't tell us how
how how much I guess altitude we're
making on each step and that's what you
have to figure out to say how many steps
you need to go up 9 feet in the air so
this is useless
so the answer is a statement one alone
is sufficient next problem
48 48 if XY is equal to 0 XY o does not
equal 0
so that tells us that neither X nor Y is
0 right is X Y going to be less is x / y
going to be less than 0
x / y it's going to be less than zero in
order for this to be true one of these
numbers so I mean if x / y is negative
that means that either X or Y but not
both of them are negative right that's
the only way you can get a negative
number when you're dividing if both of
them were negative this would be a
positive number so let's see what we can
do it there with their information
number 1 X is equal to and this is the
question is X y less than 0 and 1 says X
is equal to minus y well immediately
let's let's just substitute that back in
if X is equal to minus y then what's x /
y X is equal to minus y so you have
minus Y over Y and that will equal and
we know Y doesn't equal 0 so for any
other value other than 0 if this was 0
this would be undefined but then this is
equal to negative 1 so in this case this
is X X divided by Y is equal to negative
1 which is definitely less than 0 so
that proves our statement so statement 1
alone is all we need now let's see what
statement 2 gives us I'll do it here
statement 2 minus X is equal to minus
minus y so that tells us that minus X is
equal to Y and then we can just
substitute the same thing in again we
could say well now we could substitute
for our X well or we could just multiply
both sides by negative get X is equal to
minus y which is the same thing as this
year so statement 2 alone is also
sufficient to solve this problem and so
the answer is d each statement alone is
sufficient switch colors problem 49
problem 49 how many people are directors
of both company K and company are okay
directors of K and R statement number
one there were seventeen directors
present at a joint meeting of the
directors of companies K and R and no
directors were absent at a joint meeting
of the directors so that's all the
directors of K and R so let that let me
draw a vent some Venn diagrams so if
that is K and then that is R so they're
saying that when you add both of these
together because this is a joint meeting
of all the directors of both we got 17
so there's 17 in this entire universe of
directors that's what statement 1 tells
us that this circle that if you take
this whole circle and then you add up
the the extra don't double count the
intersection you add up the extra you
get 17 but that alone doesn't tell us
how many joint directors are joint
directors are these people people who
are on the board of both K and R so this
is K and this is R so statement 1 alone
doesn't help us although I'm suspecting
maybe in conjunction with something else
that could statement number two is
company K has 12 directors and company
are has eight directors okay K is equal
to twelve directors twelve directors
that's an i and r is equal to eight
directors okay so everything in this let
me in this in the case urkel combined is
eight right everything I'm sorry
everything in the case circle is twelve
right K directors everything in the our
circle is eight now if we wanted to get
the the total of
the K and the R so if I might buy itself
that doesn't tell me how many overlaps
so when you take statement one or
statement two independently that doesn't
help us but what if we were to figure
out if we would use them together so how
many total directors are there going to
be there's going to be the total
directors in K so Kay's directors plus
the directors in R but if you were to
just add those two up you would double
count the people who are in both K and R
right you would count them twice you
would count them when they're in K and
you would count them when they're in R
so if you wanted to figure out how many
total directors there are you then
subtract out the people who are in K and
R right you don't want to subtract them
twice you just don't want to double
count them right because when you when
you do capable sorry you're counting
them for K and then you're counting them
for R so let's subtract them out once so
that I don't know you only count them
for K or that you only count the far you
only count them once so minus K R so
this notation that's people who are in K
and R and what does that equal
well statement one told us that it told
us that their total of 17 directors and
so statement two told us there are 12
Directors in K + 8 directors in R - the
joint directors is equal to 17 and by
the way we don't even have to do this we
could have just recognized that if we
know the total number of Directors and
we know how many are in each of the
groups that we can figure it out and we
would just answer the question that both
statements together are needed to answer
this - are sufficient but I'll just show
you that we can figure it out just so
that you're happy with it let's say we
get 20 minus kr is equal to 17 and so
you get kr is equal to 3 so there are
three directors that overlap with both
and we were only able to answer that
question by using statements 1 and
statement 2 next problem
50 if x and y are positive so x y are
both positive is x y greater than one x
y greater than one is a question
statement number one tells us x y is
greater than one so let's see does that
help us at all and it's not obvious that
just tells us that X is greater than one
over Y or Y is greater than one over X
so let's just think about this statement
is equivalent if we multiply both sides
by Y and we can do that without changing
the inequality because we know y is
greater than zero so if we do that we
get X is greater than Y this is if we
can show this we can show that
and remember the reason why I could I
didn't have to change the inequalities
because I knew that when I'm multiplying
both sides by Y then Y is greater than
zero if Y was less than zero I'd have to
switch the sign right here when I
multiply both sides by but anyway if I
can prove X is greater than Y we're all
set this doesn't help me
let's see statement number two is X
minus y is greater than zero well if I
add Y to both side of this equation what
do I get I get X is greater than Y so
this proves exactly what I need to prove
it if you want to go all the way to what
originally they asked divide both sides
by Y and we don't have to change the
sign because Y is positive you get X
divided by y is greater than one which
is exactly what we needed to prove so a
statement two alone is sufficient see
you in the next video